Хронічні черги перед пунктом пропуску Шегині.
Водіївантажівок чекають на дозвіл
прикордонників.
Три години минуло і їдемо.
За даними прикордонників, час очікування на пункті
пропуску Шегині-Медика для вантажівок у лютому
становив у середньому дві години. Однак водії
стверджують, що простоювали в чергах на кордоні
від 5 до 12, а то й ще більше годин.
Хто його знає, чого вони стоять. Одні кажуть, що
поляки не працюють. Інші кажуть, щонаші.
Тяжко щось сказати.
Буває, що зависає митна система. Так кажуть…
З легковими машинами ситуація буцімто була
значно кращою. За звітами прикордонників,
за годину українські Шегині пропускали в лютому
від 30 до 50 автівок. Знімальна групаDWвирішила
це перевірити. Разом з водієм зі Львова
Андрієм під’їжджаємо до кордону.
Перед нами - не менше 20 автівок.
Треба змінити насамперед якісь митні процедури.
Пришвидшити обробку тих самих паспортів,
що вони по базі пробивають там-сям. Це все час.
Ніхто не хоче швидко працювати - ні одна сторона, ні інша.
Приблизно три години проводимо на українському
й польському пунктах пропуску
Андрій запевняє: поталанило.
Тепер ми на території Польщі, і побачене вражає.
Кілометрові черги утворюються майже щодня,
здебільшого ввечері з боку Польщі.
Причин таких затримок на кордоні багато.
Одна з них - так звані "євробляхи". Машини
на транзитних номерах дуже затягують роботу
пунктів пропуску в Польщі. Поляки навіть
зверталися до Верховної Ради з проханням
вирішити проблему з їхнім розмитненням.
Багато на польських номерах. Кожні 5 днів
виїжджають.
Інші водії очікують повернення "такс фрі", аце теж
затяжна процедура. Багато людей сплять просто
в автівках. Це підприємці, які чекають, коли сплине
доба після їхнього перетину кордону. Адже
за новими правилами ввезення товарівв Україну,
вони можуть завезти товар із Європи вартістю
до 500 євро без розмитнення лише через 24 години
після виїзду.
Скільки Витут стоїте? - 12 годин.
Я мушу тут стояти добу, щоб поїхати додому.
Нічної зміни чекають. Днем погана зміна
на українському кордоні.
Після восьмої години тільки почнуть їхати.
Наш водій Андрій їде в Перемишль і сподівається,
що черга на кордоні трохи "розсмокчеться", поки він
закупиться у польських супермаркетах.
Утім, сподівання були марними.
Ситуація на пункті пропуску "Медика"
лише погіршилася.
Через онлайн-сервіс Держприкордонслужби
з'ясовуємо, що черга на сусідньому пункті пропуску
Корчова-Краковець менша. Тож їдемо туди.
Це додаткових 40 кілометрів. Чекаємо 1,5 години,
аби потрапити на пункт пропуску.
А на"Медиці", щоб заїхати тільки на територію,
мінімум три години!
Перед нами - не менше 40 машин. Годину ми
чекаємо на польському боці, трохи більше години -
на українському. Уcумі - майже п’ять годин. І це
при тому, що документи перевірили доволі швидко.
Після введення безвізу подорожувальників
збільшилося в рази. Треба проводити якусь
глобальну реформу чи то відкривати нові пункти
пропуску, каже Андрій. Поки ж, імовірно,
комфортніше і швидше їздити в Польщу автобусом
чи швидкісним потягом.